so I thought that we had debunked all
that was going to be debunked about
coronavirus you know that 2.4 million
Americans are gonna die and we've all
got a lock down in perpetuity and that
where the LA is gonna look like Italy in
two weeks and right we all thought that
I thought that was that was all we were
gonna do Punk and then yesterday CDC
comes out it's being reported by Yahoo
News it's being reported everywhere
coronavirus mainly spreads through
person-to-person contact and quote does
not spread easily uncontaminated
surfaces do you know what that means do
you know cuz some places some headlines
they're trying to make it sound really
clinical and really scientific so that
it general that I mean they means that
the masks pretty much pointless the
gloves that people are wearing pretty
much pointless I've been saying it the
whole time I've been behaving in that
way the whole time
people have said I'm a monster I'm
killing granny I'm and it turns out we
were right we were right the whole time
the skeptics were right the scientific
experts and the lab coats who told us
all to hop on one leg and put a top hat
on while singing the national anthem and
if we don't do that we're gonna spread
coronavirus the experts who told us to
do all of these things they were wrong
okay this is this is from Yahoo News
it's not like this is some right-wing
news source even more for Co vid 19
officially had a name public health
officials said the virus could be
transmitted through infected respiratory
droplets and by touching infected
surfaces and then touching your nose
mouth and possibly your eyes you
remember that don't touch your face
don't you can't if you touch your face
you're gonna dive coronavirus so people
began snatching up face masks wearing
gloves and ramping up hand hygiene to
protect themselves while touching
infected services has always been part
of the messaging on how the virus
spreads the Centers for Disease Control
prevention recently shifted its stance
online CDC now says that kovat 19
spreads from person to person contact
and then lists touching infected
surfaces under a section titled the
virus does not spread easily in other
ways so back in early March CDC
it may be possible to spread it through
these surfaces now they don't have that
spreads through person-to-person contact
don't go around kissing strangers on the
street perhaps at least be cautious when
you do otherwise you're good
or if you're not good the masks and the
gloves aren't really going to help that
according now to the CDC so I think I've
kind of lost track of the tally but I
think we're now at the point where
virtually everything the experts told us
and then the politicians used the
experts to tell us was wrong
[Music]
you
[Music]